foreign
[Music]
and I'm here together with Keegan who is
down there getting miked up
and
today we're going to talk to you about
bees
so bees
within our users have a lot in common
with these for one thing we share a love
of hack skins
but more importantly bees are
pollinators and what we know is that the
pollinated the pollinated population
is really important to the health of an
ecosystem and I just noticed we have
this beautiful backdrop behind us with
these really nice butterflies so not not
we didn't plan this but you know it's
kind of appropriate
um
and what we hope to convince you of by
the end of our talk is that like bees
our users can enrich their own data
ecosystem with effort and empathy
so what do we mean by data ecosystem and
to explain I think it's it's going to be
helpful to tell you a bit about
ourselves so Keegan and I work at NOC we
are a non-partisan social research
organization
and I'll knock our co-workers our
partners our clients we work on we use
different types of software so SAS Excel
stata
and we produce lots of documentation so
policy briefs technical reports data
code books and we do that in a variety
of formats like word and PDF
and we work with expert coders
non-coders and everyone in between
as our users and developers we have to
leave The Hive and we have to interact
with
all these people in our ecosystem
and to do so I think
we're very lucky to have all these great
tools that folks in our community have
built to help to facilitate these
interactions
so so that's what we mean by an
ecosystem it's a diverse environment
where we have folks with a range of
skills
using different types of software and
creating different kinds of products
why do we feel so strongly about
enriching this data ecosystem
um
well three reasons so in our work we
either succeed or we fail together so if
our work is late or we passed our budget
the client is not going to care that our
team did this or the SAS team didn't do
that or manual review took two weeks
longer than uh expected
so it it's really important for us to
make sure that everybody succeeds
whether we're a SAS user or data user or
non-encoder
the second thing is
um well as our users we do better work
when others do better work so it really
helps us when others thrive
and the third thing is that the low the
more we can lower the barrier to R for
non-r users and begin our users
and the more we can show that R not only
works with other software
but it also works for other software
then it's easier for us to convince our
bosses to invest in the infrastructure
and the support to support our and other
open source software and and also to pay
for us to come to this conference next
year
so so that's why we care so much about
enriching the ecosystem
before we dive into how to be a
pollinator so just one word about what
we mean by empathy
um when you when we work at an ecosystem
you quickly realize that
different people have different ways of
thinking about the world and
biologists have a word for it it's it's
called unveiled and an unveiled is an
animal's perceptual world
so every species senses the world in a
different way so two species
sharing the same physical environment
have completely different experiences of
the same environment so bats and wheels
for example they they hear the world in
the world that human beings do not
um here is where empathy comes in so
among all the species humans are unique
in that we have a capacity to to
appreciate the unwelcome of other
species so in our context empathy means
being able to perceive code and perceive
data in a way that other people do
now
oh okay and I are going to share with
you three lessons we've learned on how
to be a pollinator and the first lesson
is Do no harm
as our users and developers it's really
important for us to be really careful
and intentional when we interact with
others in our ecosystem and when we deal
with foreign data formats
so so here is one example of reading
data from stata into r
and and they say that the the lessons
that stick with you most are the ones
you learn from your Mystics and so this
is one that's very dear to my heart
um anyways this example comes from the
General Social Survey or the GSS and the
GSS is one of the most widely cited
studies of American society it's a study
that's been run by knock for the past 50
years
and here we have an entry from the GSS
code book
this variable describes the number of
educations received by the respondent's
mother
and the code book tells us what the
unique values of this variable is
and number of cases with each value and
then at the bottom we have this section
called Reserve codes right and these are
missing values so there are three
different types of missing values and we
have 316 cases that are missing value
because they said they don't know and
then we have 100 cases that are missing
values because they said that they did
not grow up with a female caregiver
growing up so they were not ask this
question
now when we read this data data file
into r
we see that the three different missing
value types have been collapsed into a
single n a
right and and this looks bad right
because it looks like we've just lost
information
so so what do we
um well why this happens if folks are
familiar with success data is that
whereas these two software have extended
missing types so they can support
multiple missing value types R only has
a single system missing right so so what
do we what do we do about this
well it turns out that our data object
that we that we have whether we've read
in the data using Haven or we used the
foreign package the our data object
still contains these missing value types
right and it takes a little bit of
effort and a few more lines of code to
recover the different types
folks who are interested can see Haven's
conversion semantics with net for more
information about but our Point here is
that when you're working with the new or
foreign data format it really is
important to take a moment to learn
about the idiosyncrasies of that
specific format and it's part of doing
no harm
here is another example here we have a
screenshot of an Excel spreadsheet the
contents that don't really matter but
you can see that a few rows have been
highlighted and so there is data in the
formatting
and and these these could be cases that
have been flagged by a team per review
so some people have
feelings about formatting as data
um but um our view is that this data can
be in Pawn right and it's important that
we preserve this data and and the great
thing about R is that these packages
open xlsx Teddy Excel that really helps
us to retain this information in a very
easy way
and and we should take the effort a few
a few lines of code to preserve this
information
so so the lesson here is it's going to
take a bit of effort and a bit of
empathy but it's really important as
pollinators that we take care with other
people's data and we do know harm
so I'm going to turn it over to Keegan
all right can can you hear me is my mic
on awesome thank you so the second
principle of how to be a pollinator is
to make things that just work so what we
really mean by this is we want to remove
barriers for either people interacting
with r or people who are using things
that we're creating and are to make it
so that things just work for them
so a good example of making things that
just work is consider out how your data
are being outputted so you might take
the usual approach of I'm going to share
this data that I've cleaned and wrangled
in R it's really awesome looking it's
tidy I'm going to save it out as a CSV
so that's one approach
if you think about who the next user is
is going to be you could also take a
different approach and again with one
line of code here using the foreign
package we can write foreign and include
the command package equals SAS
and that gives us a SAS script so now
not only do we have the CSV but the next
person who uses this data if they're
going to use it in SAS they have a
script that reads in the data and adds
the correct formatting and labels for
them automatically
so this is a really great way to make
sure that the next person has an easier
time they go ahead and run this script
and the data just works they don't have
to go digging for the formatting and the
labels and re-encode everything in a way
that makes sense to SAS it just works
it's already there
another example is uh something you've
maybe run into a message like this looks
like there's a hiccup the server hosted
dashboard is not filtering based on the
uploaded file but it's working on my
local computer so maybe you've gotten
this message this panicked email maybe
you've sent this panicked email at some
point it's working on one computer but
it's not working on another it's working
on the server but it's not working
locally so for somebody who's not super
confident in figuring out when errors
are going wrong this can be really scary
this can be a way that they're
interacting with r that they don't know
what is going wrong and how to fix it
so we can remove this possible barrier
by from the start using something like
rnf and there are a lot of different
options but essentially if you don't
know what rnvis go look it up but it it
allows us to keep track of the package
versions we're using when we're writing
and implementing code and share those
with any other in any other people or
environments that we're going to use
this code on so the next time we go to
run this code it works on the server and
it works locally it works on your
machine and it works on my machine and
when we come back to this code in six
months it runs exactly like it's
supposed to it just works
so again with a little bit of effort and
a bit of empathy for how other people
are going to be interacting with the
things you are creating and are
you can build a positive interaction
right a positive interaction with r or
something you've created and are and
kind of smooth out those friction points
that people run into and make things
that just work for people
so the third principle is to promote
growth and we really want to bring as
many people into the r fold and into the
r community at our organization as
possible and so we do this in a couple
of ways
the first that we do pretty often is
have newer our users interact with
existing scripts and processes so maybe
a more advanced our user is going to
write a script or some sort of process
to complete a task maybe it's a data
analyst data analysis maybe it creates a
table maybe it creates a chart
and we can have newer users take that
already written code and run it with
maybe changes to certain functions
certain parameters or Flags within
within that code
and this may lead to the following
scenario
you're trying to figure out what exactly
happened to the script that you wrote so
you ran lines one through 57 then you
changed overwrite to true then 61
through 66 then back to 37 and this can
be a really kind of frustrating
conversation to have if for for both
people if you're trying to figure out
exactly what happened and exactly what
went wrong and now the person
interacting with this code who's maybe a
newer R user is going to feel frustrated
and a little scared
so there's a couple of ways that you can
just make this a little bit easier and
provide a more low risk way for them to
interact with this code
so one is you can use a dialog box so
something like the SV dialogs package
you can write again one line of code and
you can have a user go run in our script
and when it gets to a certain point
where you've inserted this dialog box
code a dialog box will pop up and give
them the option to select yes or no so
maybe it's whether you're going to
include a certain set of n a's or not
maybe it's whether you're going to run
this for males or females
whatever it is
that it's a much easier way for them to
interact with the code and it's much
less likely that you're going to run
into this tracking down what lines of
code got run at what time and what order
so with a little more effort you can
also give them a more user friendly
interface to interact with so here's an
example of a process where
we have analysts run dozens of reports
over this over a couple of months each
year and we built a shiny dashboard for
them so
um they can see what reports need to be
run there's some of this metadata here
redacted but
um how many reports are left to run how
many have already been run and they can
select a specific report in the table
and go to the details of that report see
all the metadata that they need and see
all these action buttons that let them
take certain steps in the process
so
the users are interacting with buttons
in this without actually having to run
the code themselves and they're able to
see exactly the products of this these
beautiful created our markdown documents
without having to run the code
themselves or dig into it so a good
example of how this can this can promote
growth is we had an analyst start and
say hey I'm honestly not sure what
happened I caused this error I thought I
did everything right
so I dug into it figured out the air you
know fixed fixed it and got back to them
and they said I'd really be interested
in what went wrong I really want to get
better at using R so I explained the
process and what went wrong and why it
was fixed now
cut to a few weeks later and I get the
following message after they hit an
error I'm looking at the log right now
so far I only see warnings but I'm gonna
go look for the air
so now within the span of about a month
this person went from not having any
idea how to figure out what caused the
air to digging into the logs themselves
and trying to figure out what the error
was and really kind of learning on their
own and trying to get better
so with a little bit of empathy and a
little bit more effort maybe building
out a whole user interface we've
provided people a learning opportunity
and a low risk environment to see how
how powerful our code can be and see how
it runs without having to open the door
to to maybe scary mistakes that they're
not sure how to fix so we can promote
growth in users who may be interested in
learning more
so what we want to leave you with today
is to think about the question how can
you pollinate your own data workflows
using r
so can you do no harm can you make
things that just work and can you
promote growth and I would I would pause
it that you can
um but uh thank you thank you
um but think about how you can be this
bee right think about how you can travel
between different environments and work
with different people and think about
what you can learn from having empathy
for the perspective of others and think
about what positive impact you can leave
behind with you
so thank you
foreign
[Music]